i remember reading about his
relationship with members of the
administration before i came in and what
a hard boss he is and he's menacing and
angry and all these things that you know
the press said about him and look
certainly he expected a lot from you and
i would hope a president expects a lot
from any staff
but he was fun to work around he he
appreciated what i did he would always
compliment me um so it was kind of like
a
father-daughter situation and that
i could tell he really cared about me as
a person um still does and you know i
loved him he was a great boss
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
former white house press secretary
co-host of outnumbered on fox news and
author of the brand new book for such a
time as this my faith journey through
the white house and beyond kaylee
mcinanny finally welcome to the reuben
report
thank you it's about time thanks for
having me we are long long overdue for
this conversation i've wanted to talk to
you since you were press secretary but i
reference you on the show one way or
another several times a week because i
often play clips of jen saki and then i
juxtapose her with you
but before we get to that because i'm
sure we'll have plenty of plenty of that
type of stuff can you tell me a little
bit about your bio which is partly what
the book is about
just what kind of led you to becoming
somebody that became press secretary and
then we'll get to the last couple years
yeah well like many young conservatives
across the country i grew up listening
to the great rush limbaugh my dad's
pickup truck um i used to live in plant
city florida i'd drive to tampa where i
went to school and so um i was really uh
just got this passion within me
listening to rush i love politics from a
young age going back to when i was eight
years old i just was
a burning desire and you know i worked
um through media through politics
started out at fox news as a producer
left got involved with trump world and
the rnc and the trump campaign and then
the trump white house and it just was
kind of a step-by-step ladder
progression um and one that i believe
and the title you see for such a time as
this that god wanted me there in that
moment for such a time as this um in
that time during covet 19 as press
secretary so you were a conservative
basically from eight years old and on
oh yes born and raised a conservative it
always made a lot more sense to me than
the other side
i've come to agree with you um all right
so let's talk a little bit about the the
press secretary portion of this because
i find the press secretary
the job itself to me is like one of the
most fascinating jobs on earth that in
essence you have an administration that
has talking points you have reporters
that are supposed to be asking you
contrarian questions but in your case it
was like
it wasn't just contrarian questions it
was trying to basically destroy you guys
every day
what were what were some of your kind of
guiding principles as you would you know
go into that room every day
so when i first thought about taking the
job you know i came in and i thought i'm
going to give the press a chance i know
who i'm up against this is the liberal
media i know they're going to be unfair
i've watched what they've done to trump
for three plus years um but i said let's
give it a chance and i said i'll have a
red line should they cross that red line
of going personal with me um i'll be
prepared to fight back do so politely
and gently and gracefully but i will
fight back and i won't be pummeled and
run over so my dad said to me come up
with a motto for your office and i said
offense only that's our motto we're
going to be on offense we're not going
to be the republican that lays down and
takes it we're not going to be the
administration that uh you know loses an
argument we're gonna be the
administration that brings the truth to
the american people but brings what i
think is uh what is needed most with
this press corps accountability with a
capital a uh we'll read their headlines
to them because i believe in
accountability so we'll fight back
offense only that was our motto it's the
whole title of a chapter in my book so
you did just that i mean you would read
headlines back to them you would call
them out on stories that they butchered
or ignored you'd show video clips i mean
nobody really i don't think did that
before you and saki certainly doesn't do
it since show video clips exposing the
nonsense that they were putting forth
did you feel like you were getting
through to them or that they just i mean
as most of my audience i think believes
at this point they just have their
agenda they were there to destroy you
and they're basically there to now
protect the administration
yeah i think i did get through to them i
think i remember as my second briefing
it was the first time um that i kind of
read headlines back to them because i
told you that red line was crossed
jeff mason asked a very personal
question um a out of context video clip
that um based on a remark that i made
before covid hit back when fauci was out
there saying oh covet has a minuscule
threat to our country i was echoing that
same line and uh they took that and
asked me about it in briefing number two
and you know i had conveniently just
read all of their misinformation on
covet literally right before going to
the podium so i had that tabbed and
ready to go and uh jeff mason who's
actually a nice person so i feel bad
that he was the one that the headline
uh reading happened to um but you know i
could see the audible shock on their
faces um because i was told coming into
the job half of your job is to work for
the press half of it's to work for the
president but when the press stopped
working for the people who i'm
ultimately working for um my job's not
have to work for the press anymore my
job's to work for the american people
and to me that meant reading the
headlines i do think it broke through to
them at least a little
what was the stress like just like
personally i mean it's not the pro it's
probably not the most fun job on earth
i'm sure you get some kicks out of it
and there's some fun moments but like
you know you were basically enemy number
one for these people because you were
you know sort of guarding trump in
essence
yeah i mean there were definitely
stressful days like one that comes to
mind is uh i was literally about to go
to the podium i think it was one o'clock
and the woodward book dropped that the
audio recordings on cnn so you can
imagine i prepared a whole briefing on
whatever else the news of the day was
and moments before my briefing it's
almost as if cnn had planned it uh the
drop and so very little time to prepare
i didn't have time to call people across
the administration just had to do the
best i could so days like that are
stressful but i will say we had a lot of
fun and i think that's why i believe my
press shop excelled is because we had
fun with the press we loved
brainstorming all the ridiculous things
they could ask us and oftentimes we
would find the absolute hardest question
to answer we'd identify it but because
most of them don't do their homework
usually the hardest question was never
asked so i've heard you answered this
question before but can you talk a
little bit about what trump's
relationship with you was like because
you were basically the filter to the
press if he wasn't just jumping on
twitter
yeah so he was very
appreciative of me i think he loved the
way i held the press accountable and
liked my style
so i mean i remember reading about his
relationship with members of the
administration before i came in and what
a hard boss he is and he's menacing and
angry and all these things that you know
the press said about him and look
certainly he expected a lot from you and
i would hope a president expects a lot
from any staff um but he was fun to work
around he he appreciated what i did he
would always compliment me um so it was
kind of like a
father-daughter situation and that um i
could tell he really cared about me as a
person um still does and you know i
loved him he was a great boss so when
you compare your experience to then what
you're covering on outnumbered every day
and some of the other stuff that you're
doing on fox with what goes on with sake
i mean i play clips of her every week it
is so clear to me
that she doesn't believe what she's
saying she can't in my line as always if
you asked her what her favorite color
was she would say for she cannot say
something true she said and you can read
it on her face
what do you make of the job she's doing
the way the press is treating her if it
wasn't for peter ducey i mean nobody
would be giving her a confrontational
question
yeah that's right i mean comparison you
know she was asked about the white house
cat the white house dog being involved
in fighting it incident the airport fun
color scheme i mean i was asked about
the drapes the drapes don't forget about
the drapes yeah that's rapes i mean yeah
it's crazy but what is frustrating is
she can say things like republicans
wanted to fund the police she can say
things like no americans are stranded in
afghanistan she can say these verifiably
false things which no press secretary
should be able to say because they're
just simply not truthful and then you
compare that and they just let her get
away with it very few fact checks
compare that to like when i said the
science uh should not get in the way of
opening schools because the science is
on our side jim acosta can take the
first half yep this client should not
get in the way uh make it go viral on
twitter msnbc it will be on every chiron
when it's the direct opposite of what i
was saying that they just removed the
context in that case even jim tapper
spoke out on my behalf but my point is
in one you can tell abject falsehoods
and the other you could do your best to
report as truthfully as you can the
accounts of what's going on in the white
house but you'll still be taken out of
context because you've got that r behind
your name for a republican right so i
don't want to make this personally about
her but what what do you make of someone
that could do that job like it's just so
obvious to me she knows she's lying
every bit of it like
do you think that that's just one way to
do the job
oh yeah i think if you're a democrat
it's a very low bar so jen saki can go
out there i think and she can say the
sky is red the grass is blue
and uh the street i just drove down
today was purple and the press will just
not blink an eye you know they sing
happy birthday to one another so i had
to tell you a whole lot i think there
were baked goods
transacted i believe i could be mistaken
during one briefing so um i think she
gave them cookies or something but my
point is that's the kind of cozy
coddling relationship which you know i
had diplomatic relationships with like
some members of the press like who are
great like steve holland is a great
example but by and large i don't think
jim acosta would be singing me happy
birthday or caitlyn collins or anyone
like that for the record that was the
most depressing singing of happy
birthday that i've ever heard in my life
i mean that was
that was real they did not have their
hearts in it what do we do what do we do
about the press because i i spent more
of my time i think talking about the
press and the mainstream media more than
i do about politics specifically i
actually find that far more interesting
it's like politics sort of is what it is
but it's the filter that's more
interesting to me that because that's
what shapes how we all act and behave
and think about all of it
yeah it fascinates me i think you know
one of i guess my um
deep deep frustrations is the fact you
know i brought accountability from the
podium i obviously had a massive
platform to do it you know cnn and msnbc
had to report on the things i was saying
even if they contorted it um but now you
know being in the private sector uh the
megaphone's less and it's easy to you
don't have a republican press secretary
to let go all of these stories that have
been proven false that day in and day
out i told the press so i was blue in
the face no
trump there were not russian bounties on
the heads of troops in afghanistan that
trump ignored no he did not gas and
pummel protesters to take a photo shoot
at the church these things have now been
proven false but there's just virtually
no reporting there's no megaphone like
the white house uh podium to shout that
these narratives are false but i think
the best thing viewers can do is share
with your friends hey no that lafayette
square thing yeah that didn't happen it
wasn't as reported the inspector general
found otherwise the covet lavalier
theory trump was so crazy to proffer in
fact now looks to be true so or at least
plausible so you know i think we've
gotta have accountability even in the
aftermath and that means all of us using
our tiny megaphones to create a very big
one did any of the lies get to trump i
mean the the very fine people one to me
that's what joe biden used in his
campaign launch video that trump
defended the neo-nazis and it's like no
he literally said i am condemning the
white supremacists and the neo-nazis
when he said find people he meant fine
people on the both sides of the debate
about statues generally speaking did any
of that get to him or he was just like
that's that's what it is
yeah i think you know he's so used to at
this point you know four years and he
was so used to the tired old false
defamatory labels if you're a racist
you're a bigot all of this like he was
used to those narratives i think the
only time that i really saw something
get to him and i'm sure that got to him
in the raw heat of the moment you know
years prior before i came uh but the one
thing that i saw really good to him uh
was when there was the reporting from
the atlantic that trump had called um
our fallen heroes our fallen military
men and women suckers and losers it's
the one time i saw a negative story just
um become an obsession of his because it
was just so not true so deeply hurtful
he kept saying over and over again what
kind of monster would do that we had two
dozen sources on the record with their
names on it saying this was not true um
but they ran with the egregious lie
because they were trying to leave away
the military base that is strongly
supportive of trump away from him so you
know his taxes that rolled off of his
shoulder he didn't care the new york
times hit pieces about his taxes but he
did deeply care about that
in in retrospect now that he's not
president do you guys think that uh
there were mistakes made along the way
or that you could have done something
different in messaging or anything like
that
you know looking back i don't think so
i'm very proud of the work we did sure
you know any time i wish i would have
had more time to uh deal with the
woodward story but i can't help when cnn
dropped something you know i'm someone
who uh the thing that i i like the least
is when i don't have time to prepare i
had the thick binder obviously so you
know i'd spend hours and hours and hours
so when there was a new story you know
you know i'd regret not having extra
time to prepare but no i don't think
anything i said was a mistake i'm very
proud of what we did i'm very proud of
what president trump did how is it for
you being on the other side now i mean
now you're on a daily show for an hour i
go on every couple weeks you get to
fully share your opinions that i assume
you don't have to run by anybody else
and and you're obviously pretty
uncensored as is but just being in now
you're in the media you used to be on
the other side now you're in the media
how's that shift been for you it's a lot
of fun um it is but you know i guess
being in this each and every day in a
different way uh you know i just watched
i sit beside harris faulkner and i see
what an amazing journalist she is and
you've been on with us on outnumbered
and how painstaking she is and getting
her details and her facts right and i
guess it's just um even a little bit
more frustrating to watch how a good
journalist operates and then to have to
report on how the bad journalists
operate like cuomo if you can call him
that right no you can you can't well you
can use air quotes then you can
they're air quotes exactly but you know
i love it i mean being in the private
sector is a lot of fun i get more time
with my daughter i get to come on
outnumbered with you and podcasts like
this so it's it's a different uh vibe
for sure but a fun one are you uh
enjoying the collapse of cnn the way the
rest of us are i mean you have to talk
about it when i was on outnumbered last
week we talked about it with all the
cuomo nonsense
um it's kind of what they deserve
yeah what's weird is like i was at cnn
for a year and a half about and it was
during the 2016 election so like i know
these guys pretty well every single
night i sat on the set with um you know
it was anderson cooper usually but i
would go on often to do don lemon i wake
up and do new day with chris cuomo so
it's weird because i knew these guys um
and yeah it's kind of
the um it's your comeuppance if you will
i mean i remember being on with chris
cuomo and a lot of people have forgotten
but we had a rather viral exchange where
he demanded that i call president trump
a liar like demanded it went on for like
20 minutes and then he ended by saying
you've lost all credibility with our
viewers i don't think we can ever have
you back because you won't call trump a
liar and it's just so ironic now to know
that he was lying to his viewers about
using his media contacts but yet he was
this like
this paragon of virtue um shouting down
trump campaign personnel uh because he
was so noble and forthright and honest
and clearly that was not the case yeah
what do you make of just sort of what's
happening broadly on the right right now
like it seems to be there's like it
seems very wide tent to me in some ways
and then there it also feels like well
as we get a little closer to the
midterms and then to 2024 depending on
what trump does it could all be
meaningless whatever we're seeing right
now
yeah look obviously 2022 is the most
important and that will determine i
think a lot of what happens in 2024
because it should be a total
shellacking of democrats next november
and republicans take back the house and
hopefully the senate as well but
assuming that plays out how most people
think it will play out um you know we'll
see if trump decides to throw his name
in the arena he's i think he's gonna be
a very difficult candidate to beat given
that he's got sky high popularity in the
republican party an incredible track
record you had four successful years um
and you can just contrast that to the
one year biden that's pretty clear but
we have some the great thing we have the
deep bench in our party we have ron
desantis i mean he's the best like
literally the best and um tim scott's
incredible i mean the list goes on and
on we've got such a deep bench and you
compare that to biden
and vice president kamala harris who is
now you know like a madman attacking her
staff verbally and like vastly
incompetent so these two aren't it and
they're looking to pete buddha judge but
outside of this like handful of five
people who do they have they have no one
and we have a really deep bench so we'll
see the voters ultimately decide but
between trump desantis tim scott many
others pompeo a great binge
so i've been asking everybody this but
are you surprised how quickly this thing
got so bad i mean we're only 11 months
into this and supply chain shortages
obviously all the stuff with kovid
mandates just you know gas prices
inflation the whole thing like across
the board i just don't know where you
could point to something and be like oh
no it is going well
i have to say i am rather shocked uh you
know for the first few months of the
biden administration they were trying to
put on this act of the adults are in the
room now rest easy breathe easy we have
brought back politeness
and friendship with our allies and we're
going to be praised by macron of being
back on the world stage and just they
had a lot of people fooled for about
four or five months and then afghanistan
happened and i said at the time
this is a turning point
unmistakably this is a turning point for
this administration and from afghanistan
the polling started to go south and then
everything else started to crumble bit
by bit by bit to the point where today i
see the wall street journal pull 41
approval 30 among independents so i
didn't think it would get this bad this
quick and in addition to that have
voters totally wake up and say
wow we recognize how bad it is and for
those kind of numbers to be here
in december it just shows you it's not
just the pundits noticing people are
really feeling it at home yeah so i want
to back up a little bit you talked a
little bit about kovid for just a moment
there but as everything was starting to
unfold which in crazy i mean it's crazy
to think about basically two years ago
at this point we're two years into this
can you talk about what that was like at
the beginning as you guys are getting
information as fauci's telling you
things as the cdc's telling you things
trump is you know saying close the
border with china they're calling him
racist just like the complete chaos of
like the first couple months
yeah it was total chaos because when i
showed up in the white house we were in
a nationwide lockdown i mean it was the
beginning oh right wait so you started
when in march or yeah i started i think
it was technically april but yeah
got appointed but yeah april so yeah
nationwide lockdown it was uh kind of
jarring um certainly jarring and i can
tell you this like no one wanted to not
be in a lockdown more than president
trump the businessman it was literally
killing him having to do this um you
know you had someone who i think knew
how to handle imbalance economic
interest and health interest i think he
did a great job and this president i
mean look at the vaccine mandate that
he's doing that's just killing american
businesses and de blasio tries to
outshine him by doing a stricter one um
you know it was it was definitely
strange to be in there i will say at
that time um but i i think the president
did a good job he doesn't get a lot of
credit for it i mean i was there and
jared kushner told me you know there's a
point where like we were scared you know
are there enough ventilators in this
country imagine the thought of having to
ration ventilators but the way that
jared kushner and president trump were
able to mobilize the private sector to
you know we not be so dependent on
foreign countries but mobilize it jump
start it to where we didn't have a
ventilator shortage we ended up getting
n95 mass and respirators and we were
able to uh use a businessman and the
ingenuity that comes with that to escape
some rather scary scenarios that uh it's
hard to imagine it could be worse than
the number of people who have perished
already but i think it could have been
worse if not for the ingenuity of some
of the great people in the
administration did you have reservations
about fauci and the cdc and the nih and
everything like as they were first
giving you all the information because
if you look back two years ago everybody
myself included we were all listening at
the beginning like everybody was like
yes i'll wash my bags when i come home
from the supermarket and i'll put gloves
on when i go to costco like we all did
all of this stuff which in retrospect
for me at least seems completely
ridiculous at this point
yeah in retrospect um it does i mean i
think as you said when i first got in
there you know we had the coronavirus
task force led by vice president pence
and you know falci would give his
opinion and dr burks and you know
everyone would give their opinion and
you're just trying to take in
information and consume as much as you
can so i think um you know for me early
on i was just taking in the information
and getting the words of doctors
comparing what azar was saying to berks
to falci to you know the different uh
people who had stakes in the game um fda
dr han but i mean i think it became
alarming to me when dr fauci you know
you'd get the media line up and this man
would be on like
a thousand different things and like
facebooks and i'm like how does he have
time for science when he's literally
doing like a facebook live right now
with some person and i it just i i think
the uh level of media that that he was
doing and i i get that getting
scientific information out there to the
public is important and part of the job
but i don't think it should be all the
job and he was doing a whole lot of
media and um contradicting
different people in the administration
and it just kind of became a headache
what do you think we should think of him
at this point what do you make of him
i mean two years in it doesn't seem like
it's going that well
according to that
i will say i don't know that i was
shocked per se because i think a lot of
dr falchi's kind of undoing of public
trust came in the aftermath of the
administration not so much you know
right when i was there um because as you
said we were all just taking in the
science at that point i think as we've
had time away from it we can see okay
wait he was no mask then he was one mask
then he was two masks then don't mask if
you're vaccinated now back to one mask
and we can all know that that doesn't
make sense and then i was just very
alarmed when i see him have these
exchanges with rand paul
about uh gain of function research only
to find out in his emails he was talking
about gain of function research and you
know i'm paraphrasing and
very broadly summarizing it here he
argues he was not but i think as that
came out and we started to see some of
those emails
all the pieces kind of fit together as
to who dr fauci was um and it is and he
has some real questions to answer about
what he told congress do you think it
matters if you lie to congress anymore i
mean there's so many instances of
high-level people lying to congress
whether it's you know zuckerberg or
jacket twitter talking about shadow
banning or algorithmic tricks or
whatever else or the former cia director
we don't spy on americans wittingly as
he's scratching his head because he
knows he's lying or fouchy with some of
the gate of function stuff like do you
think it does does the system function
well enough to
to do anything if if you actually lie to
congress
well i mean in effect it matters if you
are a person on the right you know if
you're michael flynn and i talked about
his case a lot at the podium you know if
you're michael flynn the national
security advisor and the deep state
doesn't like how you operate they can
corner you in your office not tell you
to get a lawyer
and essentially try to prosecute you and
use a statute that they've not used to
prosecute anyone before and it was the
logan act i mean this is just incredible
stuff but if you're dr fauci or several
of the other people you named uh then
yeah it does matter and it shouldn't
there should be one standard but uh yeah
i mean falsehoods that answered those
questions he argues it was not gain of
function research but um rand paul says
it is
yeah all right so let's shift a little
bit to the book because the tie like the
title for a time such as this it's like
we are
living in extraordinary times uh you
know it's people think it's a chinese um
well it's a curse in essence may you
live in interesting times people think
that's a good thing but it's they sort
of mean it as a curse do you think we're
living in something that's
really unique that has that is different
than you know every other every four
years they tell us well this is the most
important four years it does seem like
something's a little different this time
around
something is very different i mean we
saw an entire country collapse that we
were in for two decades afghanistan
which is literally on the verge of
economic collapse as well i mean coven
19 never ending in the left seizing upon
it to have these
orwellian rules i mean we are in a very
different time in a polarizing time
where the right and the left um just
don't see uh the same set of facts even
it seems or have much in common uh to
say the least where you have the left
trying to destroy the american flag and
what our country stands for i do think
this is an aberrational time and
definitely when i went into the
administration you know i said for such
a time as this and a reference to the
book of esther because i went in during
a coven 19 pandemic just before the
murder of george floyd where riots took
over the nation i mean it was um
unexpected to say the least the
commander and the chief
commander-in-chief getting a novel
coronavirus pathogen i mean just story
after story and then a supreme court
justice passing just before a
presidential election and then amy coney
barrett coming in i mean this was a
crazy time i mean i believe i was put
there for a reason for purpose and my
dad said to me remember you're here for
such a time as this and then democrat
cnn commentator van jones texted me
separately that same message which i
thought was interesting and i was meant
to hear who by the way van is one of the
great democrats who's out there um
despite his political leanings he's just
a really decent and uh great person yeah
there's not many decent liberals left
but but i guess he's in that in that
small pool although i don't know him
personally so this is not an attack on
him personally but he still comes off
with this woke stuff and you're just
like
come on man you're supposed to be one of
the good ones i disagree with him on all
that but yeah yeah um let's talk a
little bit about your faith because
you've you've talked about it a little
bit here and obviously it's a big part
of your life and much of what the book
is about so how does your faith sort of
frame the way you approach your job and
your life you know you were showing
pictures with your daughter in the white
house and all that kind of stuff
yeah it's important to me because um
look it's easy to go about your day when
things are going well in your life and
just plow on forward you have a long
list of things to do but i think
sometimes we're presented with um
kind of downtime downturns in life be it
you know for me in the white house it
was challenging when the president got
coveted there were many challenges so
the stresses of the job
um leaving my daughter in florida you
know all of the my health situation
where i got the bracket two genetic
mutation which put you at high risk for
breast cancer all of the like kind of
down parts of my life and i wouldn't say
the white house was a down part but
there are certainly down moments those
are the times where um as i noted to you
van jones and my dad saying the same
thing god pounds a message to my head
and very clearly speaks
to me through other christian men and
women um so for me uh it's been
paramount it's the only reason i could
go to the podium on that first day of my
briefing i was actually in my office
crying and instead of being out at the
podium because i was so nervous but got
on the speaker phone prayed with my
family and i had absolute serenity when
i got there because um not anything i
did but because of the peace of christ
within me do you think we're in some
kind of spiritual crisis sort of as a
country or maybe even as a world right
now that has led us to or at least at
least led so many people to believing
that that government in essence is god
that that is the thing that is above you
that you must bow to
oh yes um people have many gods besides
the one true god and that's a problem
you know i saw it was disappointing that
the millennial generation is
increasingly becoming detached from
faith um fewer people are going to
church i i saw that recently too and
what do you see go alongside that the
breakdown of family um a lot of the
violent crimes we see at the heart of it
is the breakdown of a family not having
good parents that you look to in life so
all spurring from not having a heavenly
father is not having an earthly family
and then you see some of the outrageous
things we see that you know we cover in
news where i'm literally having
churns on friday as we hear about ethan
crumley and i hate even saying his name
who killed fellow students at school and
his parents and and their culpability
and all of it so you know you see these
things happen um and i think when you
divorce yourself from faith from the
family unit there's a downstream effect
and uh some of the craziness we're
seeing in questioning daryl brooks
driving into a crowd of people at
waukesha it stems from something so much
bigger and i think certainly spiritual
um and those are just the downstream
effects yeah what do you think we do
about that
i think as a nation we've got to have um
you know
people are going to think i'm a crazy
southern baptist
we need a spiritual revival in this
country we need to get back to the
basics we need to get back to being with
our families getting off social media uh
getting off the video games for the kids
and having family dinners that's what we
do in my house you know every night when
i go up and uh take my daughter baby
blake to bed she sits on my lap we kneel
by our crib and we say a prayer we sit
at our family kitchen table and i'm
really bad i'm the worst in my family
about being on my device but my husband
you know ask me every sunday what's your
screen screen time this week and it's
always up but you put that aside um and
then we have our family dinners and i
think if each every family got back to
those basics and we just had basic
kindness where we complimented other
people and tried to see the best in
people rather than uh looking at the
viral twitter trolls and giving them
outside space in our minds
go a very long way is there a role for
government in any of that stuff because
you know you referenced earlier when
biden came in he kept saying we're going
to heal now
and it's like he meant you know he was
saying h-e-a-l but he really meant
h-e-e-l that we were all going to heal
to him and and bow to him
um could could we use a like is there
anything government could do to foster a
little bit of that or is it has the ship
just sailed on that do you think
i mean that's a great question
ultimately i think it's a question
that's so much bigger than government i
mean biden as you noted you know he came
in he said unity like 10 times in a
speech and he's been the most
non-unifying president like attacking
trump people and republicans and just i
think he's been caustic he's made the
divisions worse i don't know i don't
think that there's really a place for
for government i mean
certainly you know what trump did
creating opportunity zones helping to
ease people's economic burdens um that
helps in some way but ultimately i think
it's a question that's so much bigger
than government not all of our answers
lie there yeah what else so faith
politics what else and family obviously
is very important to you i mean what
else what else interests you these days
like when you wake up and you know you
got to do the daily show and do the hits
and all that what else is kind of on
your mind
uh polling
does that make me boring
like
i mean i love it's weird i love um i
don't know if you're this way but i
certainly am like where my job is my
passion so like when i people say what's
your hobby like my husband's an avid
duck hunter um and i had to interview
with the duck dynasty guys today which
was a lot of fun
yeah but he he loves he has a hobby but
like my hobby is my job so i mean
outside of like watching bad tv
sometimes like i don't know the bachelor
or something i mean i just i love my job
i eat and breathe it and my family as
you noted love going to the beach i'm a
florida girl born and raised i still am
a florida girl and you know outside of
that kind of stuff i got to tell you i
love polling i love watching the biden
numbers go down i hate it for our
country i don't want our country to be
going in the wrong direction but if
biden's polling numbers are going down i
i enjoy watching accountability
so as a florida girl who now is up in
new york for your fox gig so you're
really living in two very very like
starkly
different places how much do you see
that just in terms of interacting with
people
and just the day-to-day life that when
you're in florida the way it is versus
how it is in new york
yeah it's interesting going back and
forth because i'll never forget the
first time i came to new york um after a
long while i used to come here a lot on
the campaign because this was obviously
the center of the media universe so i
would come and do interviews but when i
went to the white house you know you get
on air force one you drift you drop down
into a city drop down into a city you
don't leave the airport he was doing
hangar rallies so you know for more than
a year i had not been in new york and
you know i had been in florida where
it's an open state people were out at
the beach people were being normal
people were walking around and talking
even at the beginning of covid when we
were in lockdown people were still going
outside we obviously wouldn't go breathe
on each other but people were going
outside and walking their dogs and
saying hi to the neighbors and you know
it just was friendly uh businesses
didn't shut down for the most part there
was a slight shutdown of restaurants and
hair salons and whatnot but generally
speaking it was normalcy and then i flew
up to new york with my husband got on an
airplane and they were like here you got
to fill out these forms and it was like
forms what forms um and the forms were
like writing down your covid symptoms
and i landed in new york and it was just
like desolation
um and cold and it was just like such a
contrast and this was more than a year
into covid19 that i made this new york
venture and just the contrast i mean
which which world do you want to live in
i think uh the answer lies in the fact
of how many people have fled new york to
go to the great state of florida yeah i
wonder was that the same day we met for
the first time it was the debut night of
gutfeld i hadn't been in new york city
since uh covid had began i remember the
streets were desolate cops everywhere
barricades everywhere we met in the
green room and then they wouldn't they
wouldn't powder me because of covid but
you were a fox employee so they were
willing to party i was just like it's
it's so it's all crazy at every possible
level every possible yeah
yeah it certainly is and then you couple
that with yeah then i started coming
back to new york regularly for
outnumbered and you couple that with the
crime i mean my goodness like we report
on it and then you also live it when you
walk the streets and just all of my
colleagues and friends
some have been one girl had mugged she
said in a very you know nice part of
manhattan and gosh colombia a young man
just killed by a knife-wielding crazy
person murderer i mean it's it's just
absolutely nuts and i know you see it
when you come i mean it it's great it's
got a little better cause it's the
holiday season and people are walking
around but uh by and large it's just a
different manhattan than the one that i
was in several years ago yeah you
mentioned de blasio before i mean can
you believe the blaze of horror that
he's going out in now with these
mandates it's like he's as you said he's
now doing more draconian stuff than even
biden i mean the federal court actually
stopped biden's mandates as we're taping
this today uh but now de blasio's coming
in with even more for new york city
yeah and it's it's harsher it's worse so
biden said okay i'm going to target
bigger businesses 100 employees or more
which isn't necessarily a massive
business but i mean bigger um and then
he says you know i'll give you four
months to get vaccinated and then this
guy de blasio says you have until
december 27th and both mandates are bad
but the de blasio one says kids have to
be vaccinated and it's look i was a part
of operation warp speed you know i'm
vaccinated but the notion that as a
parent you would force me to vaccinate
my five-year-old so it's not just me but
you're forcing me to do it to my child
and if my child's not vaccinated they
can't participate in certain sports i
mean are you out of your mind this is so
over the top overreach i've got to think
it's posturing for a delusional bill de
blasio who thinks he somehow has
presidential hopes right so so what are
you going to do i mean your your
daughter is young yet she's not in that
5 to 11 or whatever the
young
the youngest range is at this point but
like what what would you do when you
have to cross that moment
yeah i don't know i guess we'd have to
see where we are several years from now
but most kids are totally and completely
asymptomatic so the choice is you know
when i vaccinate vaccinate my daughter
against measles mumps rubella you think
of an absolutely dire outcome that
you're avoiding by a vaccination i mean
yes certainly there have been children
who have succumbed to covet 19 but it is
very small compared to the adult
population significant of course always
anytime a life is lost but um yeah
you've got to weigh the risks and the
benefits and the kind of calculation i'm
going through uh it's called liberty to
to have a well-reasoned educated
decision not have the government say
you've got to take a needle and
vaccinate your young child what if your
young child's had it and they were
totally asymptomatic and have natural
immunity you should be able to make an
educated decision that that's enough
protection against covenant 19 if you so
choose if you so choose
give me give me one other story from the
book that uh touches sort of on what
we've been talking about here
yeah there are a lot of good ones i mean
i think one your viewers would be
interested in is you know you see trump
on the campaign trail and you know he
would make these proclamations like i'm
gonna get out of the paris climate
accord i'm gonna get out of the iran
nuclear deal and you know the
establishment would say no no he can
never do that he can't do that and we
watched him come in and do just that and
it was despite the establishment saying
you can't do that that would be a menace
that would be a wreck well i saw it
firsthand it was so cool i go into the
cabinet room of the white house and
there's just this big i think it's like
a mahogany table with all of the chairs
with the cabinet secretary's names and
in this particular meeting i was there
kellyanne was there
um the attorney general was there bill
barr and some others and the president's
sitting there and i'm watching this
debate play out about whether the doj
should stay in the obamacare lawsuit uh
saying obamacare is unconstitutional and
everyone's giving their two cents and
kellyanne and bill barr said mr
president you know i just don't think
the timing of this is right and there
was an argument from some that you know
in the middle of a november election
during a covet 19 outbreak you don't
want to be seen as opposing a form of
health care however ill-conceived
obamacare was and he looked at me and
said what are your thoughts kaylie and i
said i have to agree with kellyanne and
bill barr because just politically
speaking i don't know that this makes a
lot of sense and he looked at me and
said i will always stand with my base i
will always be loyal to the promises i
made to them and i will keep them and it
told me so much about him the guy you
saw at the rally who was so authentic uh
is the same guy saying the same things
in the oval office or in a cabinet room
full of advisors telling him to do
otherwise and it told me leaps and
bounds about one the kind of man he is
um and two why he is such a success in
the conservative movement was that kind
of crazy to you i always joke about it
but it was like that this this orange
man with crazy hair was more authentic
than any of the other candidates that if
you put him next to literally any of the
democrats you put him next to elizabeth
warren it's like who's more authentic
you put him next to pete who's more
authentic you put him next to kamala
who's more it's like we all know and
it's but yet it's such a strange
comparison i suppose and yet that story
perfectly tells it
yeah yeah no it is you wouldn't think so
and i think initially when he was on the
political scene i was an early supporter
but i supported ben carson before i got
onto the trump uh team but i will say
you know politics for so long it was you
wanted the perfect candidate you thought
could relate you know pull tested
mitt romney who has just like the
presidential look and you know sleeves
rolled up and you know put him in a
a
a uh shirt that makes him look relatable
to the average guy not like a
billionaire who gets those two packs of
shirts over at costco what are they what
are they called not west lake what's
that brand uh
that brand whatever the costco brand is
i can't think of it yeah yeah and then
and then you have hillary you know let's
put up a woman and try to you know make
her drink a beer she took a shot or
something like there were just these
pull tested moments or
focus group tested moments that are
that's what they seem like and then you
just had trump who owned it hey i'm a
billionaire i'm rich that's the reason i
should be elected because i created a
multi-billion dollar business and i'm a
businessman and i'm going to wear my
suit i'm going to wear my nice red tie
and i'm going to talk about my success
and i think people just they they liked
it it's authentic and they can see
straight through the kind of mannequin
mannequin politician moves um that are
of the pre-trump era
kaylee i'm going to announce next week
why this interview was very special for
me
i can't say it right this moment i will
announce it next week but i'm so glad we
got to spend a little time together and
i'm sure i will be in the hot seat on
outnumbered soon enough and i wish you a
merry christmas
and all that good stuff well i cannot
wait to hear this big announcement um so
i can't wait thank you so much for
having me good seeing you if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about the media instead of
non-stop yelling check out our media
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out the full episode playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell